from pain from an emotional from an
emotional place I mean writing a novel
isn't a practical logical thing to do at
all I mean at least not in my case what
happens with me is that something's
bothering me or I'm feeling alienated or
isolated or I have questions about
things that are bothering me and that
those feelings begin to form an idea for
a novel and I guess that's because
that's the only way I can or that's the
way I like to express myself an artistic
in an artistic way and so what happens
like for example with imperial bedrooms
I have reread less than zero and I was
thinking about where clay was now and I
was also going through a lot of other
stuff in my life that was kind of
painful and confusing and these two
things came together the idea of where
this character was now that I'd written
about 20 years ago and what was going on
in my life at that point and then I
started to have a lot of questions about
that character and this went on for a
year so the process begins without
writing anything for about a year when
I'm just walking around asking questions
about this character and what's going on
in his life and then I start to make
notes and then I start to answer some of
those questions and then I those notes
form into an outline and then that
outline turns into a novel and that has
been my process for just about every
book that I've written
I know the last line of the book before
he actually begin the book yes another
first line under the last line and you
know and the idea I've talked about an
Outland a lot throughout my career and
I've talked about how the outlines are
often very massive and twice as long as
the texts themselves and I guess I
should just be calling those you know
first drafts in a way because a lot of
the novel is in there but there's also a
lot of other things in there there are
questions that are written in the
margins and I answer those questions and
then there are examples of how a
paragraph should look and then a note of
all the things that this narrator
wouldn't notice that I might notice or
you might notice if we were in that
scene but for example someone like lay
in imperial bedrooms who's this kind of
entitled raging narcissist would never
notice he wouldn't notice that detail in
the corner he wouldn't say that thing he
wouldn't over here that line of dialogue
and so on all of that the reader doesn't
need to see what the reader needs to see
more or less is this very pared down
version of that outline and so that's
kind of a big part of the process is
taking this very emotion based outline
and then I come in as the cool
technician and in a very neutral way try
to take this outline and shape it into
the context of an all
uh it depends on my mood it depends on
where I'm at in the novel um it depends
on how well I'm feeling that day uh it
depends on a lot of things as the novel
gets closer to completion the days get
longer and I get more revved up and I'm
more excited but the whole process I
find very intriguing and very fun and I
look forward to working on a novel
because it takes me out of you know my
mundane real life and it takes me away
from you know the pain of the everyday
in a way and I I don't understand you
know the idea of a writer sitting at his
desk moaning about the fact how hard it
is to write a novel yeah it can be a
tricky and difficult thing to do but it
should always you know be interesting to
you and something that you are excited
about its it shouldn't be something you
complain about at all but which a lot of
writers tend to do
it's not like method acting you know
it's not like you stay it's not like you
become these characters while you're
riding them I mean to a degree you do I
mean I told people for example when i
wrote American Psycho that I became
Patrick Bateman while I was working on
the book but I'm that's true to a degree
because Patrick Bateman was based on me
and Patrick Bateman was based on my
frustration and my loneliness and the
isolation I was going throughout that
time in my life and that's how that
character was based and so I did yeah
sure I live with Patrick Bateman for
four years or so and I mean I guess the
same goes for clay in imperial bedrooms
yeah there it's a situation the plot of
imperial bedrooms is a situation and a
milieu that I was um I was part of to a
degree of course in the book it's
heightened and the book is also a bit of
a Raymond Chandler neo-noir um but uh
yeah a lot of what clay was feeling I
was empathic about so yes I have empathy
for these dark characters and uh they
become darker because it's fiction is a
made-up situation there they're made up
characters but they do come from a place
of pain and they do come from a place of
darkness that does not mean however that
I am an extremely dark dude who is
walking around while I'm working on this
book you know uh you know with a set of
fangs and a cape and a really angry face
and I'm like you know I want to kill
people so no I mean it's easy to slip in
and out of it
I shall my work to know one the only
person who sees my work after all the
time I spend on it is my agent she's not
the first person who reads the
manuscript I've never shown any
manuscript to anybody except for less
than zero which was being worked on
while I was at college and my professor
at the time Joe McGinniss read a couple
drafts of that book but since then no
and you know the reason is because I'm
again it's a personal thing I mean I'm
not writing a novel to be accepted and
I'm not writing a novel for a consortium
you know I'm not writing a novel for an
audience and I'm not writing a novel for
a reader so this idea that you need to
show your work to people and you need to
get feedback and oh is this section
working I mean I really want you to know
Paula tell me Hey Joe what do you think
about this because it just doesn't play
a part of the process because to me it's
my emotional journey in a way and it's
and it's a very personal thing and I
there's just it has even crossed my mind
to show the book to anybody